sometimes girls get exhausting right so
it's like I like how your face is very
telling too I'm going to go hang out
with the home girl oneon-one typically
it's usually going to be an emotion Fest
and I'm just there to listen a lot of
guy friends don't know that they always
try to fix it or I have a lot of guy you
try to fix a girl problem impossible I
want them to but they never can we don't
have the solution either it's too
pragmatic you know what I'm saying do
you feel like that even with your wife
with my wife I don't give her any advice
cuz she'll sock me so I just like I also
think I have a little bit of a cheat cat
cuz I grew up in a beauty supply store
so I was around women all the time you
know what I mean and just yap yap yap
yap yap all the time